the sole leader in the event after three
rounds world number two fabiano caruana
fabi we're making this point about great
games being played by other players like
spectacular brilliancies but it's all
about taking the lead winning what you
need to win and being ahead at the very
end and this game was certainly a beat
down as well you played well today it
looks like yeah i was proud of this game
i'm not sure if you were complimenting
me or insulting me with that i was
complimenting you all right thank you no
this i thought this was a good game um
the i was of course uh i did get a very
undeserved win against peter
i mean
uh a draw would have been normal i was
worse throughout the game
uh
and we went to rook ending which i
assume like i'm i'm on the slightly
worse side of the draw and then he made
a few inaccurate moves in time trouble
and suddenly it became very unpleasant
for him
but uh but at least i was i was happy
with the first two games also the game
against levon
um wasn't the perfect game but i felt
like
the
the quality was there somehow i was i
was happy with my play you know you talk
about perfect game
in chess 960. it's it's not like you get
to prepare the opening lines and play
flawlessly for 20 moves and then you you
play another 10 moves of perfection and
the game's a draw what is it like having
only 15 minutes and you see this crazy
position on the board the first one had
the bishop sitting on e1 and d1
yeah that um i actually think that the
broadcast broke on that game which was
unfortunate because it was a pretty i
think interesting game and we just i was
with lev on upstairs uh and we were on
uh on a phone call with leonard
transcribing the moves for him right so
now the the score will be we were able
to keep up uh some of the moves he
ourselves watching you but yes it was uh
it was challenging but it it's fun to
play because uh you get a fresh position
so
uh our mornings are not bogged down in
uh thinking of what to do against uh
against players going through databases
you know
um like today we just played tennis uh
there's there's nothing to do there's no
preparation to do so we have 15 minutes
before the game that's it
um it's not enough time to get any sort
of clarity like there's
um you might
you pretty much can't even analyze the
first move like in the
in the first game uh levon played d4
and i expected b4 i played c5 and i
expected dc5 and he played d5 and that
was it we were on our own
um
so like i haven't been able to prepare
more than two games in two moves in any
of the games
amazing
uh
speak to the contrast because you're
telling folks you know you you don't
have anything to do in the morning how
many hours how much time would you
normally spend if you had to prepare for
for games that were coming uh for rapid
not much i would just decide on my
openings and maybe within an hour i
might do it the night before as well i
just want don't want to get to the board
and not have any clue of what i'm going
to do um at least i decide my setup
and and of course i'm i'm not going to
be able to prepare for all of the
options that my opponent might have at
his disposal because
uh players have pretty broad repertoires
but at least i i know if he plays e4
i'll play the sicilian or you know if he
plays d4 i'll play the nimzo et cetera
um
so there's at least some thought that
goes into it uh while here there's
nothing you can do you just you just
show up and
at the board pretty much and uh
and play we saw some crazy things today
hikaru nakamura on oh and three that's
pretty wild thought yeah that was really
that's really unexpected uh
especially since that at fast time
controls he is uh he's at his best
um
and i think he's pretty comfortable
usually in
uh in fischer random
uh but things just went it looked like
he was out of form i mean he blundered
against sam it was a beautiful blunder
but
it was still in uh
an unusual blunder for him
and uh another two games also it looked
like he was kind of not at his best
what's it going to take for you to keep
this lead and maybe extend it
i'm not
yeah i don't feel much pressure it it's
more of a fun event there's not a huge
amount at stake uh
five
37
dollars or first hey if you don't want
them i'll take them you can give us we
don't mind
um no there's of course money but uh
uh and the desire to play well but it
still feels like a more relaxed
atmosphere all right well get your fun
in maybe tennis again tomorrow is the
formula
congratulations on taking the lead today
thank you